I love my parents because I am an adult
I'm a grown-up yeah I have friends
grown-up men and women who say things
like oh I hate my mother and I'm like
what are you for nobody got enough hugs
hug yourself walk it off
people who hate their parents have
unrealistic standards they think parents
are these superior beings and they're
not they're just people who suck like
the rest of us that's how we should
introduce them just like these are my
people Rhonda and Tim they do what they
can set the bar low
have you guys realized that your parents
messed you up yet yeah you find a stray
dent in your hand you're like what
happened they're like we did our best
that's what happened there you were
slippery so have you guys had this
happen as adults where you realize your
parents messed you up based on how other
people react to stories about your
childhood stories you thought were fine
cuz when you're a kid you're stupid
you're just like everybody gets tied in
the yard like you don't know fast
forward 10 years or to barbecue
everyone's going around swapping stories
like oh my god my mom was crazy she used
to make us take our shoes off in the
house and you're like I know we wore
muzzles at night
what happened wait everyone gets sad
my parents are cool they're very
religious that's how I was raised
I'm not super religious anymore I still
believe in God
I think cuz I've invested so much time
into the idea yeah cuz if there's no God
then I told the wind a lot of secrets my
dad's very conservative he still thinks
gay people shouldn't be allowed to get
married which I know you ever hear older
people say stuff and you're like who's
someone missed a software update like
that's time can't just say that anymore
out loud we're in a target we go
it's crazy he taught show choir for ten
years and the whole time he was like
homosexuality is a sin and we're like
without homosexuality you would not have
a job those sparkly teens put food on
our table don't fight the jazz hand that
feeds you
growing up he encouraged me to abstain
from drugs and alcohol and sex and
enjoyment and I really took all of that
to heart even today I'm as an adult very
sexually conservative not that I'm bad
at sex okay I'll have you know in bed I
am a wild animal all right yeah way more
afraid of you than you are of me I was
abstinent all through high school didn't
need to be no I was trying to get in
here didn't need to lock the door no one
even jiggle the handle as it turns out
but I signed the papers and people don't
realize how scary it is being an
abstinent teen girl cuz friends of mine
to be like Oh months I'm pregnant
I miss my time in a month I was like oh
no I'm carrying the Messiah that's a lot
of pressure I don't know any carpenters
but it's so easy to mess kids up I have
a lot of respect for parents even
babysitting I just babysat for a friend
of mine I was so nervous about it I
didn't want to mess the kid up so I was
like I'm just gonna put on a movie I'm
not gonna talk to it and everything will
be fine so I put on a fairytale princess
movie little girl she's four adorable
she comes running up to me 20 minutes
into the movie and goes Taylor was being
in love feel like right I was like what
how do you explain love to a child that
young how you begin to explain romance
and dating and courtship you know it's
complicated there's an app and you got
to download it and swipe
you gotta lie a little bit fill out a
resume take a picture from here like
it's a whole thing
but I wanted to be honest so I thought
about it carefully I'm like what does
being in love feel like that's similar
to something she's done and I went okay
do you remember when you got lost at the
grocery store that was scary right but
then do you remember the feeling you got
when you finally found your mom how safe
and happy and relieved you were and how
you ran up to her and you grabbed her
leg and then you looked up and it wasn't
your mom
that's kind of what it's like out here
ya know you think you know a guy turns
out is just some stranger with your
mom's knees trust no one
swipe left
you